trois hectares supplémentaires pour un
parc qui en couvre déjà 227 c'est un
agrandissement d'un peu plus de 1%.
chaque pied carré compte dans notre
ville on va déminéraliser le secteur le
re natureliser dès 2024 les abords de la
maison Smith ressembleront un peu plus
au décor original sur les quelques 725
places de stationnement au sommet de la
montagne 300 seront supprimés pour faire
place à une clairière on promet
d'améliorer l'accès en transport en
commun je suis venu le week-end puis
dans pendant le temps des couleurs puis
il y avait des line-ups
on parle de crise environnementale donc
là on fait quoi on a un choix entre
entretenir un îlot de chaleur
ou encourager un îlot de fraîcheur où
est-ce qu'on va soutenir la biodiversité
dont les 20 prochaines années Québec va
aussi céder à Montréal plusieurs
terrains de l'ancien Royal Victoria
comme ce stationnement quasiment
abandonné il faudra attendre 2033 car il
sert encore à quelques utilisateurs un
horizon un peu trop lointain pour
certains moi j'invite les différents
parties prenantes et essayer de trouver
des actions peut-être même temporaires
mais qui vont permettre de commencer à
s'approprier ces nouveaux secteurs avec
une nouvelle entrée par la rue
University le poumon vert de Montréal
devrait être encore plus accessible
depuis le centre-ville et lorsque toutes
et tous ont accès de manière équitable
nos parcs sont des leviers extrêmement
puissants pour réduire les inégalités et
des piliers de l'adaptation à la crise
climatique
la pandémie a rendu le mont Royal encore
plus populaire on compte aujourd'hui
près de 40 km de sentiers informels qui
sont un autre danger pour la
biodiversité la ville a pour objectif
d'enfermer et d'en reboiser 5 km par an
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal